well we in our class are nearing the
phases of deciding which organizations
were going to donate to and you have
plenty of experience in doing that one
of my top concerns is how to manage risk
so in the field of philanthropy maybe
even more so than the field of business
many individuals and NGOs face failure
and actually accomplishing their goals
how when you give your money do you
assess these risks and take these risks
into account when you donate I think you
have to be willing to fail and I'm a
great believer no matter what you're
doing that it's important to be bold and
take risks and and to allow
organizations that are doing but you
you're really in looking at an
organization and how you're going to
give your money away you have to
evaluate you know are they going to do a
good job are these people who know how
to manage the organization do they know
what they're doing and do you feel
comfortable making a commitment but I
still think you have to bet it's worth
it taking taking risks and actually when
when Warren Buffett spoke to Bill and
Melinda he wanted was one famously said
is don't just go to safe places really
tackle tough issues and if you're going
to tackle tough issues you've got to
take risks so what's your passion I well
one of the organizations that we're
thinking about is called mycelium school
and it is an organization well it is
it's only just beginning and it like the
founder believes that in our current
model for education today we don't have
enough emphasis on action on actually
doing things putting our learned
knowledge into action so he wants to
incorporate that into the field of
social enterprise and create a school
based on that philosophy but it's never
been done before we don't know the
person personally and it's just I think
it's very hard to assess the success
rate of an individual that we've never
met but I think if I were
single-handedly making the decision in
the class I would love to be able to
give mycelium school a chance can you in
her for you feel a mild skype yeah we
probably can we would definitely try to
do that yeah well would see some of the
questions you would ask him oh I guess
you know what is his approach how does
he go you know what her to what is his
strategist he have a strategic plan save
a three-year strategic plan is he
looking long term how does he see it
evolving who are the other investors
does he is he investing in it mm-hmm how
much weight do you put on the idea
versus the the talents of the person
who's supposed to execute the idea I
think I probably weigh them equally that
idea usually get you involved but the
talents really is having strong
management is really critical you know
having somebody who it really knows how
to think and the act and and to really
move a project forward would you agree
with this statement one of the things
that you said it seems radical which is
just be willing to take risks you have
to be willing to fail and where I see
it's not radical is from people who come
out of a culture of innovation people
come out of Technology and so when we
hear of people who have created great
wealth in the technology sphere they say
similar things to what you just said
that is so important that if you're
going to have an outlier response you
have to be willing to take resilience be
able to fail or scientists say that you
have to it's not a negative thing you
just exclude that its information you
exclude that but when you speak to other
philanthropist who have been around and
are more traditional or in an inherited
wealth sort of context there's a
different level of timidity and it's as
if you get defunded if you fail because
you should have all succeeded but it
would cut the world's complex problems I
don't understand why your point of view
isn't winning out over the other point
of view it
as if you're not being innovative and
willing to fail and fund people who are
failing you're not going to change the
world I think it's really critical that
you be willing to I don't think of
myself as a philanthropist you know I
have lots of patience and as an art
museum director and other things
although you know the family is
everybody is a philanthropist um to some
degree but in the art museum world I
tell people you've got to take risks and
you've got to be bold and I think no
matter what you do in life really taking
risks it when an opportunity presents it
season it and going with it is important
and I think it plant be you can't you
you have to be willing to let people
fail my phone oh thank you so much for
coming that's great to have no sir so
one of the premises of this class is the
idea that the donor has taken a hundred
thousand dollars and allowed 25
different people to sort of make this
decision rather than centralizing that
decision with a single person and I'm
curious how you I mean you're you're
close to a foundation which is in many
ways where the most centralized giving
sort of operations in the world I'm
curious what do you think what are the
advantages of having such a sort of us a
centralized model versus a more diffused
giving a lot of people who want to thank
giveaway type of approach well somehow
you have to you have to reach a focus
right and so I'm sure I mean how have
you all been able to reach and focus we
are you still in on monday and i think
that's something that we're we're
Francis you're not a few days going on
right now that's what we're trying to
figure out it's very difficult I make
decisions by myself which I like and not
not by commit the foundation they now
are very targeted they have global
health they have global development and
in the u.s. education and then Northwest
giving is a small piece and libraries
are small piece okay you probably read
about it so yeah so there's different
parts to them but the ultimate New
Year's in a lot of decision kind of
comes down to Bill actually bill and
melinda or do they delegate do but they
also they
read avidly okay young bill he reads
voraciously and he has a memory where he
never forgets okay and yeah you know it
could be hiv/aids it could be osteo
samaya sis you know all these different
things he actually has really on
vacation take 14 books well okay and
they're not books not fiction that I
would you know and and he really learns
about and he also hires people who are
the best experts in their field and its
really worked and they also had somebody
in education they weren't keen it was on
dividing large high schools in the small
high school and they really decided that
was not the best strategies so they
turned it over they actually hired
somebody new and now they have different
strategies okay so being being willing
to adapt and maintain I think
maintaining flexibility is really
important but it's interesting as to how
25 of you how you come to a decision
you're all happy with and you know that
encompasses so do you put it in
different buckets how are you dividing
it up well at the moment we divided into
three focus groups there's a global
health group poverty alleviation group
and a social justice group so that gave
us at least somewhere to start on
focusing which organizations we might
want to consider funding and now we're
trying to narrow it down to a top list
of ones that were really passionate
about and then from there the debating
starts so it's interesting also what
you're what you're not including yeah so
you know for me the arts I really are
really vital and I'm going to just ring
it read you a quick quote which actually
comes from Michelle Obama which the arts
are not just a nice thing to have her to
do if there is free time or if one can
afford it rather painting and poetry
music and fashion design and dialogue
they'll define who we are as a p
ball and provide an account of our
history for the next generation and I
think the Arts in terms of enabling us
to explore who we are and who other
people are that they really also free
you up to to look at the world in
different ways in the see different
world and also cultural organizations
most many people assume that ticket
sales pay for the entire organization
which is not true and what did those
organizations mean the community and
that's something to think of and it may
not be affect you right now but when you
live in a community think about what the
arts and culture mean you know can you
imagine Paris without the Louvre New
York without the Metropolitan or but
these organizations and it's the same
thing for symphony orchestras where
almost all of them had some meaningful
impact on our lives and to keep them
going it's worth thinking about some
piece of philanthropic giving